we begin our 7:30 half-hour this this is
very serious at Wisconsin man who
admitted kidnapping 13 year old Jamie
cloths and then killing her parents is
due to be sentenced this afternoon 21
year old Jake Patterson has not
explained why he held this girl captive
for nearly three months until she
escaped Jamie yuccas is inside the
County Circuit Court in Barren Wisconsin
with the latest on this story Jamie good
morning a lot of people waiting for this
day oh absolutely good morning Gail Jake
Patterson faces a mandatory life
sentence for his crimes but the terms of
that sentence will be decided in part by
the testimony of Jamie's family members
who are expected to appear here in court
later today guilty Jake Patterson will
return to the same courtroom today were
less than two months ago he pled guilty
to a crime spree that brought this
close-knit northern Wisconsin community
to a standstill their dispatch center
where the call happened was right down
there and Chris Fitzgerald is the Barron
County Sheriff
seems like forever ago that we were all
here saying where's this
thirteen-year-old girl on the night of
October 15th
Patterson forced his way into Jamie
Casas home murdered her parents James
and Denise and abducted their only
daughter Jamie was held in captivity
around 60 miles away at a home owned by
the Patterson family the barren
community spent 88 days searching for
her before she escaped
Patterson faces a mandatory sentence of
life in prison I am so proud to present
our hometown hero award to miss Jamie
cloths last week Jamie made a rare
public appearance at the Wisconsin State
Capitol where she was honored for her
bravery the cloths family has kept a low
public profile throughout the ordeal
a few days after Jamie returned home her
family members spoke to Gayle King we
have to take little steps Jimmy when
she's ready to talk she will the thing I
want to wanted to express to her
immediately and we all do is the pride
we have in her for doing this forgetting
out for making it now sheriff Fitzgerald
says the community is ready for some
closure is this town ready for this
sentencing to be done yeah I think
they're ready to move forward you know
justice to be served and I think it
be the big lesson is that you never give
up hope
we're told the hearing could last up to
three hours Jamie closest family members
have shown up to every court appearance
and the community is so committed to
seeing what happens many told me they've
taken off work to watch the hearing at
home we did reach out to Patterson's
attorneys for comment but Gail we so far
have not heard back Jamie have you heard
if Jake Patterson is going to say
anything in court today you know that's
obviously of interest to everyone
in the state of Wisconsin he does have
the right to speak we know that he's
reached out to a number of news outlets
in the past and seems to want to speak
but at this point his attorneys have not
gotten back to us on this point and I
asked the sheriff specifically and he
said he doesn't know yeah the answer the
question everybody wants to know is why
and no matter what the answer is it's
never going to be satisfying but I'm not
surprised that the Claus family is there
when I was there they're tight they're
very respected varied Mart and beloved
in that community so they will have a
lot to say that's a very hard moment to
get through a family and it's great that
they're doing it together yeah